so how do you work with directors who
get so married to that plan that they
they just can't deviate from it because
that's how they saw it and they know
their vision is you just just trust me
on this and this is going to work we've
just got to do it this way okay this is
a plan in terms of shooting the film
certainly film but with the scene with
actors with visuals or what what aspect
okay with with an actor and let's say
the actor was one way in the audition
and one way in the read brought a good
level of emotion and then you get them
on set and they've kind of retracted
into a little bit of a shell but it's
working in some ways but not the way you
envisioned it so you can still play the
scene but they're going to be a little
more awkward and introverted not maybe
more emotional how you wanted them to be
okay
okay so there's been an adjustment
within performance that you may not have
asked for but it's there
right and you're saying it it's good
it's interesting but it's not what you
wanted or thought you wanted say back in
the hustle and pre-production right and
now you're shooting anybody and so what
do you do what do you do because even
though yeah it looks good and I like in
other people the other actors are
feeding off the energy ice it's got to
be this one way okay the first thing is
the idea it's got to be this one way is
a trap watch out for that because I can
tell you right now as a director - a
director this idea of while you're
shooting knowing precisely what you want
and you're going for that is a problem
not a problem going for it but it's a
problem believing that if you have that
then you're fine because I know exactly
when you'll know what you want from that
character in that scene and that's in
post-production in post-production
when you're editing that scene together
and this has happened many many times
seeing it way too many times you edit
the scenes again and go okay it looks
good looks good got it then you put the
whole movie together and
how that scene isn't looking so good
anymore because it's part of a stream a
movie is not a bunch of scenes linked
together it's a stream it's a constant
movement it's a constant movement of
characters and now there's suddenly
these two characters hitting that scene
and something is off now maybe it's too
restrained maybe it's too enthusiastic
maybe it's something there's something
that's tipping something wrong now so
the big question I went to
post-production that scene as in quite
working what options do you have to fix
the scene because I can tell you and
again I've seen this many times at that
moment you go I know I didn't need but I
don't have it we didn't shoot it that
way we didn't shoot it where she's more
restrained and we didn't shoot it where
he's more adamant we didn't shoot it
where the emotions has more conflict we
didn't shoot it with the more sense of
sympathy or empathy or whatever whatever
you think you know if we had that we'd
be great so the question really becomes
why didn't you shoot that the reason you
didn't shoot that is because you didn't
think that's what you needed
even if someone had suggested even if I
had been on the set with the director
that this has happened a few times
I said are you sure you don't want to do
one more where she's a little more
restrained or one more wishes which is a
little bit more out of control or try
one with a slight difference no no no
I'm fine since I hear I'm fine I just
can feel that chills like oh because you
don't know no major exercise told me you
don't know so a lot of directors I work
with was fine with them I say you sure
you want to do that visual it'll take
less time to shoot that than it would be
to argue it
so I say shoot it now this comes back to
Robert Altman okay Robert Altman who I
knew for a while and when I was in New
York he was directing a play starting it
played that my wife at the time was in
called come back to the five-and-dime
Jimmy Dean Jimmy Dean Robert Altman is a
obviously a master film director into
a film director who had done theater
before if I came down another play with
another friend of mine Frank salty Dan
play with his so he knew about theater
but now he's doing a big Broadway show
and because my wife was in it I was
allowed to come in and sit in on
rehearsals and I was at one time now
Robert almond has like six week
rehearsal period which is typical and it
was about two is about halfway through
it and he had the whole play staged he
had tried a lot of different things and
you could see he was going I don't know
what to do next I don't know what to do
next now I being the arrogant person
that I am and sort of cynical said to
him well one thing you could do is try
all the things you know won't work and
he says that's great let's okay so he
started doing the craziest things let's
try it this way now this is theater and
being my background being theater this
is what we do with you we try things
that don't work we tried things
nassim ridiculous way outside the box
and he started playing with it and the
actors loved it and all that but the
important thing is what he said later he
said Denise as I get it the rehearsal
process in theater is the same as the
editing process in film now when he said
that first I didn't quite get it and I
thought about it and I went wait a
minute he's right the rehearsal process
in theater is a process of trial and
error
experimentation let's try this doesn't
work let's try that all that work let's
keep that let's good and even in terms
of script you can be changing things
until you can keep changing them so it's
a trial and error period leading up to
opening night and eventually you narrow
it down to this we're going to play it
this way and even then day before you
open you could be trying things the
editing process is a similar process
it's trial and error let's cut it
together this way let's try it this way
let's try it with this moment let's try
cutting the scene this way but the thing
is the difference between theater and
film in post-production film if you
don't have the material you need to go
through a trial
an error process you can't do it you
look at that actresses performance and
you say I've got four takes of her doing
it every time she did it she did it
pretty much the same way that's all I've
got
so you don't have the choice my
recommendation to every director I work
with and this is the way I shoot stuff
my job impotent not post-production my
job in production is to create the range
of material from which I will choose
later I don't have the way to do it I
have a rate now I have in my mind I know
what I want but I also want a range a
material way beyond that sometimes the
most ridiculous thing and the actors
know that fact I tell the actors I don't
know how I want this to play I don't
even know how I want the entire movie to
play they said you don't know so we're
going to keep experimenting we're going
to shoot a lot of rehearsals we're going
to kill it
and the actress relax they go oh the
pressure is off I'm not trying to hit a
perfect performance because mark doesn't
know what it is I said no I don't know
what it is I'll tell you what I think it
could be I could be wrong so even this
last thing I shot just a few weeks ago
and I said to the actors and I always do
this I said okay let's do a few more
just for you be outrageous I asked the
act the acts be outrageous go way
outside the box as far as you want and
we shoot that and some of that stuff is
amazing and we use it had no idea this
is staying open but it's going into
post-production with all this range of
material out of which myself and the
editor could start to create the scene
as you know in a film the scene is not
created when you're shooting it the
scene is created in post-production and
we will create a scene that never
happened it never happened that
three-minute scene never was played that
way until that is but that's that three
minutes is made up above with seven or
eight different performances so there is
no perfect performance and that scene is
cut in relationship to the rest of the
movie and I need that range of material
and/or
to do that it almost sounds like a new
director would have more of that mindset
where I have to get it is specifically
this way but then ones that sat in an
editing Bay and have seen and been the
position of I don't have any filler and
I can't change it around yes and this is
why some of the best directors we have
and you just recently when we're
off-camera you mentioned who you
mentioned Sidney Lumet all right Stanley
Kubrick clearly Kubrick Cassavetes a
Bergman who all worked in theater now
directors who've worked in theater
understand this process absolutely good
sale that's my process my process is
rehearsal trial and error rehearsal
trial now not trying to nail something
down before I'm done it's all trial and
error and so the directors understanding
that process and this is why when I
consult with directors I take them
through what we call a workshopping
process I take them through with their
film this trial and error process even
before pre-production with actors so
they can start to see how this can work
they can see the range of possibilities
and get out of their mind getting back
to your question the releasing from
their mind the feeling that is using
releasing from their mind the feeling or
the belief that they know how the movie
should be played that's not important
like that's a trap I know how the scene
should be played that's a trap better
way to think about a scene is I know how
I want this scene to hit me emotionally
I know that which goes back to the
script wash I know how I want to be
kicked by the scene my gonna I have no
idea how I'm going to get there and it's
going to be trial and error right up
into the last edit until I can look at
it that's it it's doing it it's doing it
it's doing it to me this scene that I
was just talking about that recently
shot a shift
in the music that the editor came up
with a slight shift that he did he did a
miraculous thing and this was a scene
that I was directing and I was directing
it for in front of a group of directors
that I was talking about earlier that
came from overseas for this workshop
demonstrating all these techniques but
the scene in the editing was shifted
dramatically this is really interesting
in terms of the trial and error as the
editor was cutting together he picked a
piece of music he thought would be
interesting on the scene I liked it we
changed the Edit which means the Edit
now that piece of music didn't fit
anymore and he took it out an else and I
went oh no we want to keep that in but
we but there was another piece of music
we wanted to come right after two
different pieces of music by the same
composer same artist well they don't fit
together at all and we can can't we keep
that one in and put that one in he goes
no no you can't I won't work but he as
an editors knew that we wanted to do
that and by actually manipulating the
second piece of the music changing the
key that it was in he made am it good to
go and suddenly the scene started
working again
now that's trial and error
that's the editing process now that was
just a piece of music has nothing to do
with the performances but it was
suddenly it underlined what was going on
in the performances and so you have to
keep your mind open to all these
possibilities constantly one of my
favorite quotes is from Sydney
who I know a little bit when he said he
said making movies is great I love the
process of making voices this is only
one problem you have to understand
Sydney came from theatre too and worked
with Sanford Meisner and all that he
says there's only one problem with
moviemaking eventually you have to show
it to somebody which really means it
eventually you have to stop the process
of making the movie the process of
making a movie is great but when you
have to lock things down ago that's it
that's the hard part that's the most
painful
are
you